president trump will be among more than
130 world leaders expected to attend
meetings at the united nations this week
tomorrow the president will deliver his
biggest speech
of the week when he addresses the
general assembly he is expected to talk
about protecting u.s sovereignty and the
need for other countries to do their
part in protecting global stability
british prime minister theresa may will
raise important global issues at the un
like the iran nuclear deal and the use
of chemical weapons by russia
britain accuses russia of poisoning four
people in salisbury england
only on cbs this morning we visited the
prime minister's office
or i should say official residence at 10
downing street in london
for her only interview ahead of the
general assembly
when you talk to president trump does he
listen yes we have very good discussions
and these are i mean the the the point
of the
special relationship between the united
kingdom and the united states in a sense
is that we can have those frank and open
discussions
uh and when we disagree we will we can
say to each other we disagree and why
we disagree um but at the same time we
cooperate
on so much else which is of crucial
importance to us
clearly obviously security and defense
being key to that is there an instance
in which you think he listened to you
and his behavior changed well i think
that we have
uh we have a number of
conversations about these issues and i
think we have
we've been talking about issues around
trade about the importance of nato
i think i was the first leader to come
after his inauguration we were able to
talk openly about
the value of nato and and he reconfirmed
the american commitment to nato
when you when he tells you something do
you trust him
of course i listen and to what the
american president tells me
do you trust him well yes
i mean we we work together we have a
special relationship
this is uh two people reflecting
as leaders of their two countries um at
the
relationship that those two countries
have and have built up
over a number of years and
as we work together you know let me give
you a very good example
i spoke to president trump after the
salisbury uh
attack took place he said he would expel
russian intelligence officers he did it
you also it was reported asked him to
raise it with vladimir putin
in helsinki he didn't what what did you
make of that
well there's uh he raised a number of
issues raised in that uh in that
discussion
the uh well i i i how can
i think vladimir putin is in no doubt
about the view that we have about what
happened on the streets of salisbury
i just wondered whether it could have
been amplified by the american president
saying
given the special relationship which was
built around common defense of course
in churchill's original speech whether
that could have really
sent the message home in a personal
weaning i think expelling 60 russian
intelligence officers sent the message
home pretty clearly
uh how high up in the russian government
do you think uh you you've
said the gru is involved in this
poisoning does it go all the way up to
vladimir putin
we believe that certainly the two
individuals identified were officers of
the gru
and that the decision to undertake this
was taken outside of the gru and at a
senior level
could be putin we believe it was taken
at a senior level
who's responsible for the state of the
relationship between the international
community and russia
well the russia it's russian actions
that is leading to the international
community's response
the reason i say that is the president
president trump said um
we're both to blame when asked that same
question
i think what i am reacting to as a uk
prime minister
and i think what uh the international
community reacted to including the
united states
after salisbury was action that russia
had taken
on the streets of the uk has iran been
holding up its end of the bargain
of the 2015 deal well this is
the the question of that deal of course
is uh an area where i do have a
difference of opinion
with uh with president trump uh because
we believe the jcpoa
should stay in place and others uh
involved in putting that deal together
believe that it should stay in place
we do agree with the united states that
there are other aspects
of iran's behavior that we need to be
dealing with too
um so looking at the issue of ballistic
missiles looking at the way in which
iran is acting in the region and to
destabilize the region
we need to address those issues too but
we also want to ensure that we have a
nuclear deal in place
that prevents them from appearing of
getting a nuclear weapon but by your
assessment
iran is keeping up its end of the
bargain we from what we see
we believe that it is uh doing that how
can you make progress on something like
chemical weapons when deals can be
just walked away from like the jcpoa
well the important thing about the jcpoa
about that nuclear deal
is that it is still in place yes united
states
has taken a particular view on how to
deal with this issue
uh that's a view which we disagree with
we we take a different view
but that deal is still in place
lots of news there yeah i'll say she did
seem to have a little bit of a hum and a
home in a moment when you said
do you trust the president first she
didn't ask didn't answer the question
you had to
rephrase it and the way she cocked her
head well that of course
i guess would you feel that in that
moment yeah i did she was working very
hard to not say anything
critical of the president and you know
we'll we'll have this later in the show
but it's amazing
she is in the middle of trying to
restructure the entire economy of
england i mean she's got a huge job on
her hands so
it was fascinating important interview
thank you john